recently I've been mostly indulging my
casual EDH instincts in my videos as I
think there are lots of often neglected
things to look for in a deck aside from
its ability to win unfortunately those
things are going to have to go on the
back burner for this video because I'm
going to be talking about how I built my
sweatiest deck a deck whose construction
process focused on making it as powerful
as possible on the budget I gave it my
hope is that this video can serve as a
bit of a guide on how to build something
powerful without breaking the bank a
useful thing to do in a game where
different players have different
monetary resources to build decks with
with that said my construction of this
deck began in the place where a lot of
decks start figuring out an intriguing
Commander to look into in this case I
opted for the partner Commander pairing
of Malcolm Keeny Navigator and Francisco
foul Marauder a pair I picked out
because I enjoy deir and I also enjoy
Pirates malcol is going to be doing the
heaviest lifting of these two generating
Treasures whenever I hit opponents but
Francisco is no slouch either offering
great filtering and rapidly building up
in power and toughness for purposes of
smacking my opponents and ultimately the
she versatility that this pairing offers
is what makes them so potent my mindset
going into building this deck was this
if I make Francisco and Malcolm my
default turn two and turn three plays
and then land a one drop pirate as often
as possible this will leave me with a
powerful filtering and treasure
generating engine fully online by turn
three so that's the resource generating
core of my deck Francisco Malcolm and 10
one cost Pirates some of these are a bit
janky but they perform the function of
being a one cost pirate which is all I
care about once I had my commanders and
the first 10 cards out of the way I
began to do research I was looking to
build a new high power deck and I knew
that my starting point was pretty strong
so I began looking around for good ways
to end the game figuring that I'd need
something a bit more focused than just
hitting people with whatever Pirates I
have laying around front and center on
the Eda track page for Francisco and
malcol were thesa Oracle based combos
one of the strongest combos in EDH but
this combo would have eaten a lot of my
budget and I frankly just find it kind
of bland I looked around a bit more
before being reminded of a card that had
in the back of my mind for several years
time Civ and that card seemed decidedly
more my speed see Malcolm hopefully
creates three Treasures per turn and
times siiv spends five artifacts to
Grant an extra turn something you may
notice is that these two numbers three
and five aren't very far apart with two
additional artifacts per turn we can
just keep on taking turns indefinitely
with this Revelation I went looking for
things to help me bridge this Gap a card
that immediately jumped to mind was
Academy manufacturer and this ended up
being accompanied by storm Fleet
negotiator an evasive pirate that
typically produces two to three map
tokens per attack the third dedicated
option I have for this is World Walker
Helm a card printed in the big score
that operates very similarly to
manufacture and this ended up replacing
ruthless n as my third supporting piece
there are also a few cards that produce
one artifact per turn as well as some
cards that are or that produce a single
artifact and I call these play extenders
cards that serve to buy the deck time
when it's beginning to take extra turns
but doesn't yet have a way to guarantee
these turns being indefinite after
adding all these cards to boost time Civ
up to being a full combo plan I decided
to add some tutors to find my combo the
fact that world Walker Helm and Academy
manufacturer are artifacts is great as
it means that artifact tutors can find
everything we need to win so naturally
we start here with fabricate reshape and
were of invention all artifact tutors
that effectively cost three or less Mana
for purposes of finding time siiv these
are accompanied by limd Vault and ring
site both somewhat more generic tutors
that can find a wide range of cards
though Vault can require a hefty shave
off my life total if I'm going for a
specific card such as time siiv these
five tutors are supplemented with three
transmute cards which are great for
their flexibility as they can either be
cast normally as control spells or be
transmuted to tutor for a card of their
Mana cost with two and three being the
key Mana values in this deck so with
that I had the deck's engine and I had
the deck's wicon but what ended up
rounding out the other 44 non-land cards
in the deck to get to that I need to
talk about perhaps the strangest thing
about this deck its extreme consistency
I can basically present what this deck
is trying to do as a five turn map turns
1 to three in a conventional game
consist of a one cost pirate turn one
Francisco turn two and Malcolm turn
three turn four is the setup turn where
I play any other cards that might assist
in my combo turn five is the combo turn
this is usually the turn where I'll
tutor for my time siiv if needed play it
then hopefully begin a series of however
many turns are needed to beat down my
opponents sometimes turns 1 to three go
a bit differently usually if I don't
have access to a one drop or if I have
something different I want to play on
turn two or three but needing to play
Francisco or Malcolm turn turn four is
decidedly not the end of the world the
fact that I have that turn where nothing
needs to be played gives me a little bit
of wiggle room in my curve out the deck
also varies a little bit in when it goes
off sometimes I'll delay the combo to
turn six especially if I needed to spend
my treasures interacting with my
opponents in some way on an earlier turn
likewise the deck is able to combo off
on turn four about 10% of the time when
things line up just right though this
also usually means going for the win
without counter spell backup so I'll
only do this if my opponents are tapped
out or if I expect one of them to do
something big on their next turn the
speed of this deck is limited by the
fact that Malcolm generates at most
three Treasures per turn meaning that it
generally takes multiple turns with
Malcolm on board to generate the
treasure surpluses needed to go off to
talk about what I chose for the rest of
the cards in this deck I need to go back
to that critical setup turn turn four
this turn is where I develop all manner
of things that might be useful for
purposes of comboing off the first of
these is draw for isco's filtering is
lovely but I found that if I don't
already have what I need to combo in
hand I'm generally using that filtering
to aggressively dig for tutors and combo
pieces passing up potentially useful
cards for that reason having a bit of
draw in addition is good and there's one
particular type of draw that stands out
above all others in this deck cards to
let me draw when I hit people this deck
runs all four Biden ofasa effects that
exist and this is for good reason
Landing one of these on turn four is
great that extra stream of cards almost
always Smooths out any issues I might
have in comboing off and these effects
can even generate enough value to let me
keep up as a mid-range deck in the event
my time sive Bites the Dust other draw
effects include combat research curious
inquiry and curious Obsession the draw
post combat is nice and plus one plus1
is also nice for if I'm going into turn
three with a 01 Francisco and want to
play that plus a two drop rather than
Malcolm the rest of my draw Suite has
been rotating around a bit between
different options currently I'm running
treasure Crews and dig through time
delve cards that can utilize the
unnecessary stuff that Francisco has
dumped into the graveyard another type
of card I tend to develop on my setup
turn is Mana rocks since all of these
tap for Mana immediately the two Mana
ones effectively cost a single colorless
and weaving them into a turn four can
offer a nice burst of Mana for my early
combo turns and also an artifact to be
sacrificed to time Civ if needed the
last main type of card I find myself
playing on my setup turn is additional
Pirates theoretically a one drop pirate
a Francisco and a Malcolm maxes out my
commander Tri triggers per turn but
realistically creatures die sometimes
and there are also games where I have a
one drop on the ground and need a flyer
for an opponent with blockers or
alternatively an unblockable creature to
get past Flyers an opponent has some of
my Pirates have that extra little bit of
evasion and others have other upsides
such as having some sweet removal staple
to them or offering a bit of extra
filtering a final supportive pirate is
Oak siren a bulk common that feels like
it was designed just for this deck it
flies it can tap post combat to cast my
combo pieces and it itself is an
artifact that can be sacrificed to time
siiv beautiful card love it since this
deck is still a pirates deck in addition
to being a combo deck I also ended up
adding an alternative wicon haunted one
this card pumps my team's Power by four
if both commanders swing which can turn
a handful of evasive Pirates into a
veritable player killing machine at this
point I need to get to arguably the
thing that gives the deck most of its
power the interaction Suite my deck is
running 13 counter spells a number that
may strike a lot of casual EDH players
as mildly obscene but this number works
out well for a couple reasons first of
all the de core is very compact being
comprised of the command Zone and 19
cards from the deck even having added in
a bunch of utility stuff to help smooth
things out there's still a lot of space
to work with and counter spells are a
great way to fill that space because
they can both protect what I'm doing and
hinder what opponents are doing the
other reason counter spells work so well
is because of treasures I've talked
before about the issue of counter
counter spells effectively wasting Mana
if they aren't used and a great thing
about Treasures is that they're never
wasted Mana due to their one-time use
nature the fact that they serve this
dual purpose of being both stored mana
and also artifact tokens for time save
is quite good I can tap out every turn
and still have Mana available for
counter spells if they're needed now
spending Treasures to play counter
spells is still consuming a resource so
a lot of times I do leave up a land or
two to reduce the number of treasures I
need to sacrifice but even when I do
need to spend Treasures it's usually
fine the deck can often sacrifice a
couple treasures and still combo off on
time and even when it does need to spend
enough Treasures to delay its combo by a
turn that's still not too bad for me as
it forces my opponents to spend mana and
lets me avoid needing to cop up the Mana
to recast Malcolm I'm also running some
number of removal spells though this
count can afford to be lower since I'll
have counter spells to counter spooky
things before they hit the board and the
deck also aims to win before most decks
get around to playing a lot of big bombs
lastly I'll just talk briefly about the
Mana base this deck's Mana base follows
a simple principle I want untapped
colored Mana as often as possible
following from this goal every single
land in the deck can theoretically play
a pirate turn one and though this means
running some spicy lands such as
gemstone mine that can see diminishing
returns later these are worth it for
purposes of guaranteeing that I'm able
to send up my engine correctly this
desired For Colored Mana also motivates
the next land count currently sitting at
35 my curve is extremely low and Cisco
actively encourages me to run fewer
lands I want him to hit a non-land guard
on his first explore trigger so he can
attack the following turn and he also
offers a way to dig for additional land
plays in games where I keep a twoand
hand and if I had access to expensive
dual lands that could guarantee having
the colors I need I probably would cut
at least two lands but since I don't
have access to these I've opted to stick
with my current land count though I may
experiment with cutting down to 34 lands
at some point all right so I've been
hyping up this deck a lot and it is
quite good however there are some
notable weaknesses with the deck and I
think it's useful to talk about these
and think about how to solve them the
first is that it usually won't have Mana
to deal with removal before the end of
combat on turn three Malcolm generates
Treasures when pirates connect with
opponents but if an opponent has an
instant speed kill spell for Malcolm
before I get Treasures the deck has no
response unless it has a foil or
misdirection in hand and it will likely
need to delay its combo attempt by one
or more turns this issue I'm currently
choosing to take the L on as it has only
come up a couple times and the free
counter spells I'm not currently running
aren't all that appealing to me another
weakness that I alluded to earlier is
that this deck's engine relies on
dealing combat damage to opponents so if
there are one or more opponents that
it's unable to attack the deck won't
perform at full efficiency this issue is
decidedly more manageable the deck's
commanders already have flying and most
of the Pirates in the deck have either
flying or a more robust form of evasion
the deck can also usually afford to only
hit two opponents for a turn or two and
Francisco gets big pretty fast so a lot
of times the best bet is to send him at
the opponent with flyers and force chump
blocks in order to open up that opponent
for further attacks I've also considered
cards such as thieves tools to help with
this though I haven't felt the need to
add that just yet the third weakness of
the deck is the most problematic and
also the most complicated and that's
that the deck has a difficult time
recovering from major setbacks the main
reason for this is that the deck card
quality just isn't that high and in my
opinion this is the biggest factor that
holds this deck back from competing with
competitive EDH decks cedh decks
typically have very high card quality
with most non-land cards being extremely
efficient and or flexible even in Yuro
the cedh deck that's most similar to
this one there are powerful supporting
cards with impactful effects that
require no setup and no other cards to
utilize by contrast this deck has a lean
Mana curve and much of its space is
dominated by cards that don't do much
without its commanders in play even the
bigger draw spells require creatures in
play to be good and though the deck has
plenty of counter spells to keep away
board wipes during its most pivotal
turns I've had games where things
stalled out and the deck's board
eventually got worn down through
attrition this is the weakness that I'm
trying hardest to solve and I've had a
few ideas a funky card I'm trying out at
the moment is ecostorm which functions
as a play extender if I'm trying to
combo and it can also be a big burst of
value off a single card if I'm trying to
recover from a point of my commanders
getting killed multiple times I may also
opt to trade out a couple removal spells
for additional draw which would help in
general with stall outs and hopefully
prevent me from fully losing my board
solving a budget related problem without
increasing the budget of the deck is
difficult but it's a fun challenge to
Grapple with even with its weaknesses
this deck does a good job demonstrating
what higher power commander on a budget
can look like or to some extent what it
needs to look like you can build a lot
of different decks up to a relatively
high power level but as you creep into
the higher end of high power casual and
begin to approach the wild world of cedh
decks need to be very streamlined in
both what they do and how well they can
stop other people from doing things and
this becomes doubly true when you add in
a budget element that restricts card
quality ultimately building a deck of
this caliber on a limited budget relies
on having two interconnected attributes
an efficient game plan typically helped
out by a powerful command Zone and also
a high interaction density I like to say
that the best way to build a strong deck
is to take a fundamentally broken Magic
card and put it into your command Zone
and while this statement isn't untrue a
more helpful phrasing might be that it's
helpful to have your command Zone
contribute to both resource generation
and to defeating your opponents in this
case my command zone is part of an
infinite turns combo and it also offers
some ramp and filtering we can see this
pattern echoed in other powerful budget
commanders such as NIV mizette eureco
and elev of the wild Court the fact that
these sorts of Commanders support aex
game plan so holistically is important
because it allows that plan to be
relatively compact for how powerful it
is not occupying too much Deck space
when you're evaluating powerful
Commander decks what the deck is doing
proactively to win and what the deck is
doing reactively to deal with opposing
plays often exist in a state of tension
due to deck space being limited so
naturally if you're able to improve the
efficiency of a deck's proactive game
plan and let it keep up at the same
power level with fewer slots this will
give the deck more space to be faster
more interactive or a little of both
that interaction density is the other
part of what makes powerful Commander
decks so powerful I know a lot of casual
EDH players who dislike counter spells
but the fact that they can both hinder
opponents and protect your own game plan
from hate is very useful and the
usefulness of both them and removal
actually scales with deck speed one of
the reasons people don't run much
interaction in casual Commander is
because the format is full of dirly
mid-range Decks that are going to be
playing out a long stream of nasty high
cost spells in the late game and dealing
with one player's cards often just
allows a different player to play their
stuff unimpeded but when your opponents
only have a handful of turns to develop
their concerning things before you're
threatening a win the number of things
that actually required dealing with will
often be smaller and easier to dismantle
countering one of a player's three bombs
isn't all that great but countering a
single combo piece or value engine or
board wipe can sometimes be enough to
slow an opponent down for long enough to
execute a win to cap off this video I
would like to re re iterate decks being
strong isn't everything and a lot of
players are decidedly not looking for
Cutthroat games with tables full of fast
combo decks I can't really play with
this deck in my normal play group
without it feeling wildly out of place
which is kind of a downside for a deck
to have i' also argue that the current
EDH space puts too much emphasis on ways
to improve the raw power level of decks
without considering how playing with or
against these decks ends up feeling at
the same time it's a fact of life that a
lot of people are looking to make their
decks more powerful this is a
competitive card game after all it's
also a fact of life that different
people have different amounts of money
that they want to spend on the game and
that fact can be felt in the power of
decks sometimes proxies are one solution
to this issue but they will never be the
whole solution if for no other reason
than that they're not allowed at any
Wizards of the Coast Affiliated event
just as it's useful to know when to hold
off on cramming powerful cards into a
deck it's also useful to know exactly
how to ratchet up the power of a deck
when you want to do that and being able
to do so without needing to crank up the
card quality with expensive Staples is a
great skill to have thanks for making it
to the end this video ended up a little
longer than I was intending I'm going to
be doing another Deck review this month
over on my patreon so if you want a
chance to get your deck reviewed by me
you can head over there and start giving
me money sometime in the next 5 days if
you give me enough money you can even
join the people you see on screen here
pretty tempting huh